[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers
Ihnen allen einen guten Sonntagabend
abgeschlossen erledigt Ausrufezeichen so
sieht der bayerische Ministerpräsident
mit dem heutigen Tag die Affäre um
seinen Stellvertreter Markus Söder lässt
Hubert Aiwanger im Amt alles andere wäre
aus seiner Sicht nicht verhältnismäßig
abgeschlossen und erledigt so sieht das
auch alwanger selbst verbindet das ganze
aber mit massiven Vorwürfen spricht von
Schweinerei behauptet der
nazi-massenmord an sechs Millionen Juden
werde gegen ihn instrumentalisiert und
es sieht so aus als ob er mit der Affäre
um ein widerliches Flugblatt voller
Judenhass auch Wahlkampf machen will
abgeschlossen erledigt wirklich oder
Gerät da ganz generell etwas ins
Rutschen in diesem Land mit seiner
Verantwortung vor der Geschichte wir
beginnen unsere Berichterstattung heute
Abend mit Patricia Schäfer über einen
denkwürdigen Tag in Bayern
heute Vormittag im Bierzelt Hubert
Aiwanger wirkt gelöst wie befreit für
seinen großen Auftritt am Tag der
Entscheidung hat er sich freundliches
Terra ausgesucht ein Zelt voller
Anhänger der Freien Wähler es ist kurz
vor 11 und Ellwanger macht sich bereit
zum Angriff
[Musik]
[Applaus]
skampagne auf keine Spur von Demut oder
Reue es ist 6 Minuten vor elf noch hat
Markus Söder seine Entscheidung nicht
kundgetan da kommt Aiwanger den
Ministerpräsidenten zuvor
raus Bayern wird auch ab Herbst
weiterhin von freien wählen und sie
he zu leben
die Koalition wird fortgesetzt und
Aiwanger setzt noch nach
sollten die schwächt werden
ist nur ein schmutziges Wort Wert von
dem sich viele noch werden distanzieren
müssen zur gleichen Zeit in München
Ministerpräsident Markus Söder auf dem
Weg zu seinem Statement in der Causa
Aiwanger um Punkt 11 Uhr tritt der vor
die Presse um fünf nach elftern der
entscheidende Satz
daher in der Gesamtabwägung
das kein Beweis vorliegt dass die Sache
35 Jahre her ist und das seitdem nichts
Vergleichbares vorgefallen ist wäre eine
Entlassung aus dem Amt aus meiner Sicht
nicht verhältnismäßig aber Schwamm
drüber oder weiter so wären auch der
falsche Weg sagt sogar noch er liest
alles vom Blatt ab und trägt seinem Vieh
zum Ministerpräsidenten Aiwanger etwas
auf auch wenn all die Sachen lang her
sind ist es wichtig die Reue und die
Demut zu zeigen das Hubert Aiwanger war
dann arbeitet verloren gegangenes
Vertrauen zurückzugewinnen so dass er
auch Gespräche mit jüdischen Gemeinden
suchen sollte
und vieles zu erklären und gemeinsam zu
besprechen im Anschluss an das Statement
wurden die 25 Fragen veröffentlicht die
die csuiwanger gestellt hatte samt
Antworten darin nicht viel Neues und
weiterhin große Erinnerungslücken wieso
waren die Flugblätter in ihrer
Schultasche mir ist dieser Vorgang im
Detail nicht in Erinnerung haben sie das
Flugblatt weiter verbreitet sie Antwort
zu Frage 1 warum ist der Verdacht damals
auf sie gefallen das entzieht sich
meiner Kenntnis
Gott beschütze Bayern Dankeschön zurück
im Bierzelt der Freien Wähler wo eine
drückende schwule herrscht was man
Hubert Aiwanger am Ende seiner Rede auch
ansehen kann wir fragen nach
[Applaus]
gesprächig
das muss jetzt prüfen und in den
nächsten Tagen hier die Gespräche
zumindest vorzubereiten und dann
okay nicht viel Neues auch beim
Krisenmanagement Reue und Demut Hubert
Aiwanger will jetzt nur noch nach vorne
blicken
florian ist bei uns der Fraktionschef
der Freien Wähler im Bayerischen Landtag
schreibe
erledigt findet ihr Vorsitzender wissen
Sie denn jetzt was wirklich war an sehr
viel kann sich Aiwanger ja nicht
erinnern er entschuldigt sich nur für
was eigentlich das sagt er nicht
na gut entschuldigt sich für die
Verletzung die durch sein Verhalten als
Jugendlicher auch irgendwo beigefügt
wurden wenn das falsch verstanden oder
worden ist also dass man hier dann
natürlich auch sagt es ist dann auch
manches schief gelaufen in der
Vergangenheit und was wir aber
eigentlich nur wissen ist diese
Flugblätter sind Fakt und die waren im
Schulter Ranzen und wenn hier durch
gerade bei der jüdischen Kultusgemeinde
Verletzungen entstanden sind
Irritationen für entstanden sind dann
tut es ihm und Leid und dann muss man
natürlich das ganze auch irgendwie
wieder Vertrauen gewinnen und hier ins
Gespräch kommen sie sagen entschuldigt
sich für sein für seine Verhalten in der
Jugend welches Verhalten konkret meinen
Sie denn
gut also es ist weil die sehr
irritativierende also
Berichterstattungen waren es wurde ein
Bild gezeigt von einem 16-jährigen
Jugendlichen des ja unschön ist
scheußlich ist aber das mit den Hubert
Aiwanger den wir heute kennen also
nichts zu tun hat aber dadurch sind
natürlich Irritationen entstanden
Verletzungen entstanden von diesen Bild
her und das muss man natürlich dann
irgendwo auch zurecht rücken und für
diese Irritationen dafür gehe ich davon
aus dass er sich entschuldigt hat so
ganz verstehe ich immer noch nicht
schreibe Hubert einfacher spricht heute
oder in der Antwort auf diese Fragen von
einem Zitat einschneidenden Erlebnis das
wichtige gedankliche Prozesse angestoßen
habe er kann sich aber nicht erinnern
was dieses Erlebnis genau war wie soll
denn das zusammenpassen
an was er sich natürlich erinnert ist ja
dies auch dass er uns Direktorat gerufen
worden ist dass diese
Pamphlet auch da war also dass das
natürlich eine einschneidendes Erlebnis
ist allerdings wenn es so wie es er
sagte ja auch ist dass er das ganze
nicht geschrieben hat aber trotzdem wenn
man ja Gegenstand von solchen
schulischen Ermittlungen ist dann ist es
natürlich ein einschneidendes Erlebnis
und ich denke als dass das natürlich
auch dann etwas auslöst in einen jungen
Burschen dass man dann über das ganze
auch verschärft mal nachdenkt und sagt
was habe ich da eigentlich in meiner
Tasche gehabt
reden wir über den heutigen Tag gucken
auf den heutigen Tag sie selbst kennen
die CSU ganz gut ihr Vater war
csu-ministerpräsident in Bayern wie hat
der aktuelle Ministerpräsident aus ihrer
Sicht diese Krise jetzt gemeldet
also aus meiner Sicht hat sie sehr klug
gemanagt und hat natürlich also sehr
abgewogen und hat alle Argumente für und
wieder also auf dem Tisch genommen und
hat sich der auch Zeit genommen um das
wirklich von allen Seiten zu betrachten
und hat dann nach meiner Meinung eine
kluge Entscheidung getroffen denn allein
aufgrund der Tatsache dass ein
16-jähriger Schüler vor 35 36 Jahren
etwas in seinen Schulranzen gehabt hat
was da nicht hineingehört kann man heute
einen Minister nicht aus den Amt
entlassen und von so äh sind wir
natürlich froh über diese Entscheidung
von
Ministerpräsident dr Markus Söder denn
dadurch wird die bayernkoalition jetzt
auch fortgesetzt auch mit Hubert
Aiwanger fortgesetzt und wir können im
Grunde ja in eine neue Legislatur
hoffentlich dann auch gut starten
Koalitionen hängen nicht an einzelnen
Personen hat
der gesagt sehen Sie das auch so
naja Koalitionen hängen immer an
Interessensgemeinschaften dass man etwas
gemeinsam voranbringen möchte für ein
Land und Personen gehören aber auch dazu
denn es kommt auf die Personen letztlich
an in einer Koalition ob die miteinander
können ob die nicht miteinander können
dass hier als Vertrauen gegeneinander da
ist also von früher kommt sie auf die
Personen drauf an und von sowas immer
auch um diese Entscheidung jetzt heute
froh weil das auch wieder ein
gegenseitiger Schritt des Vertrauens und
der Vater uns vorhin Zusammenarbeit ist
würden sie jetzt heute abend sagen
weiter mit der CSU nach der Wahl das
geht auch nur weiter mit Hubert Aiwanger
na gut in der Wahl wir haben achten
oktober wird der Wähler entscheiden wie
es weitergeht und wird das Ganze auch
bewerten ob hier dann eine Mehrheit für
CSU und freiwähler da ist und dann
müssen sich Koalitionäre zusammensetzen
und überlegen welches Programm was man
weiter verfolgen möchte und natürlich
auch über Personen reden und deswegen
jetzt so ein bisschen Kaffeesatzleserei
wenn man sagen würde es geht nur so oder
so aber ich gehe davon aus dass auch in
einen neuen Kollektion Hubert Aiwanger
eine entscheidende Rolle spielen wird
interessant was sie sagen sie gehen
davon aus sie machen das aber nicht so
Voraussetzung dann noch eine Frage die
mich sehr interessieren würde wir haben
jetzt von Norbert Aiwanger neben den
Entschuldigung und der Reue auch viel
Angriff gehört er sprach von
Schweinereien von einer Hexenjagd wird
das jetzt in Zukunft Teil des
Wahlkampfes der Freien Wähler sein in
dieser Form
also es ist natürlich hier also auch bei
Hubert Aiwanger Verletzungen entstanden
Irritation entstanden die auch
aufgearbeitet werden müssen allerdings
sind wir immer auch bemüht um einen
guten und fairen Umgang also mit der
Presse weil hier die Journalisten und
Presse gehört auch zum demokratischen
Kultur bei uns im Land und von sowas bin
ich der Meinung dass man hier jetzt
einmal vielleicht alle auf allen Seiten
bisschen abrüsten muss sag Florian
schreibe der Fraktionschef der Freien
Wähler im Bayerischen Landtag erschreibe
herzlichen Dank live nach Oberammergau
rechts rechts herzlichen Dank nach Mainz
danke schön so dann gucken wir jetzt auf
die Folgen für den Ministerpräsidenten
und dessen CSU die sind unabsehbar und
man darf davon ausgehen dass unabsehbar
ungefähr das allerletzte ist was ich im
Markus Söder vorgestellt hat für die
heiße Phase eines Wahlkampfs der für ihn
ohnehin nicht ideal lief ein Wahlkampf
in dem er sich früh und kategorisch auf
die Freien Wähler auch als künftigen
Koalitionspartner festgelegt hatte heute
hatte Söder noch einen wichtigen Termin
ZDF Sommer Interview mattes Feld das
zusammen
Markus Söder hat sich viel vorgenommen
Aiwanger kritisieren Aiwanger erklären
Aiwanger die Absolution erteilen Söder
ganz Landesvater gewährt heute Vergebung
die Grundlage so der Ministerpräsident
sei vor allem ein persönliches Gespräch
mit Aiwanger ich hatte das Gefühl dass
auch seinen
seine Reue und auch seine seine
Distanzierung von dem Flugblatt und dem
Inhalt des Flugplatz des
zugegebenermaßen ekelhaft widerlich oder
eine Nazis Wirkung war das war für mich
glaubhaft am Ende es ist ein
hochkonzentrierter CSU-Chef und
Ministerpräsident der da zum zdf-sommer
Interview gekommen ist er weiß er muss
die Waage halten zwischen Kritik an
seinem Stellvertreter und der Botschaft
dass man zusammen weitermachen kann was
ein 16-Jähriger macht es nicht so
entscheiden es kommt schon drauf an wie
man dann als 52-Jährige damit umgeht und
sie haben auch recht ich habe das auch
betont das gerade am Anfang ist
Krisenmanagement und sagen wir mal sehr
unglücklich war er hat dann aber am
Donnerstag und das ist jetzt der
positiver Aspekt wieder dann sich klar
davon distanziert hat sich entschuldigt
der Vorwurf geäußert von der
bundesinnenministerin und vom
Vizekanzler es ging es Söder allein um
die macht ihn treiben die Angst vor
deren Verlust wenn er so nicht stehen
lassen seine Entscheidung sei nicht
spontan sondern wohl abgewogen Angst ist
für mich keinen Muster
nicht kennt weiß dass Axt jetzt auch
kein Motiv ist nein am Ende ging es mir
darum einfach fair zu sein aber mir ging
es einfach ums vielleicht auch deshalb
kritisiert Söder die Medien vorne weg
die Süddeutsche Zeitung ohne sie
namentlich zu erwähnen als wolle er den
Eindruck erwecken man hätte über das
Thema auch einfach hinweg gehen können
die Geschichte scheint ja auch so haben
wir es gelesen ich glaube sogar im
Spiegel auch anderen Medien angeboten
worden zu sein die haben es aber nicht
abgedruckt weil sie offensichtlich das
nicht als so stark empfunden haben doch
auch Markus Söder will und kann nicht
einfach die einwangerische Vergangenheit
ignorieren zu viel steht im Raum doch
von ihm lassen will er auch nicht
wir in Bayern sitzen Klarheit auf die
Koalition mit den freien Willen wir
haben fünf ja gut zusammengearbeitet
übrigens auch keinen Zweifel gehabt an
seine Haltung doch dieses Vertrauen
scheint zumindest erschüttert Markus
Söder verlangt jetzt eine Art
demokratische Bewegung von seinem
Stellvertreter
der Wahlkampf läuft auf Hochtouren in
Bayern per Brief kann man bereits wählen
Katharina Schulze ist die
Oppositionsführerin im Landtag und
Spitzenkandidatin der Grünen in Bayern
jetzt bei uns Frau Schulze guten Abend
schönen guten Abend in der Zeitung steht
sie duzen iwanger scheinen ganz gutes
Verhältnis zu ihm zu haben vielleicht
sagen sie auch Hubsi zu ihm ist die
Sache für Sie jetzt auch erledigt nein
die Sache ist für mich nicht erledigt
ich finde heute war ein sehr bitterer
Tag für Bayern allein der Anschein von
Antisemitismus in der bayerischen
Staatsregierung schadet dem Ansehen
Bayerns und ich finde Markus Söder hätte
heute für Klarheit sorgen können er hat
sich aber für macht er halt und Taktik
statt Haltung entschieden aber setzen
sich doch mal ganz kurz vielleicht in
die Rolle von Markus Söder hinein es
gibt aktuell ja viele anonyme
Beschuldigungen gegen einwanger es gibt
keine echten Beweise und Aiwanger selbst
kann sich an vieles nicht erinnern was
soll denn ein Ministerpräsident in so
einer Situation tun
naja es geht ja bei dem Thema schon um
was Grundsätzliches und zwar unserem
demokratischen Grundkonsens wie halten
wir es mit der Erinnerungskultur und
gerade auch Hubert aiwangers Umgang mit
den Vorwürfen hat ja schon einige Fragen
aufgeworfen erst hat er alles von sich
geschoben dann kam die Wahrheit
scheibchenweise ans Licht dann gab es
eine Entschuldigung nach dem großen
Druck und kaum hat er sich entschuldigt
hat er gleich eine Kampagne gewittert
und ist jetzt wieder in den
Angriffsmodus gestartet das alles ist
für mich kein glaubhafter Umgang mit
Verfehlungen in der Jugendzeit sie sagen
also der Umgang ist eigentlich eher das
Problem als das was damals passiert ist
werden wir denn jemals wirklich wissen
was passiert ist damals
also ich für mich ist ein
antisemitisches Flugblatt im Rucksack zu
haben keine Jugendsünde wie es manch
einer gerne formuliert und jetzt hat
Hubert jetzt hat Markus Söder erneut die
schützende Hand über Hubert Aiwanger
gehalten Hubert Aiwanger der
stellvertretende Ministerpräsident der
auf der Demonstration in Erding davon
schwadronierte die große schweigende
Mehrheit müsse sich die Demokratie
zurückholen ich finde die Menschen in
Bayern haben eine Staatsregierung mit
Anstand verdient die die Demokratie
verteidigt und die klare Kante gegen
Antisemitismus zeigt das sind für mich
Uhr bürgerliche Tugenden sind sie auch
deshalb heute so enttäuscht weil Markus
Söder selbst in dieser Situation jetzt
in der er steckt Ihnen also den Grünen
noch mal eine klare Absage erteilt hat
Tür zu für schwarz-grünen Bayern
ich bin damals in die Politik gegangen
weil der Kampf für die Stärkung der
Demokratie und der Kampf gegen Rassismus
und Antisemitismus mich politisiert hat
und ich finde einfach es geht bei dem
Thema um was grundsätzlicheres jeder der
jetzt in Zukunft was antisemitisches
sagt kann sich dann eigentlich am
Endeffekt auf den stellvertretenden
Ministerpräsidenten in Bayern beziehen
für mich ist da heute was verrutscht im
Umgang mit der Erinnerungskultur und
dafür trägt auch Markus Söder
Verantwortung was machen Sie denn aus
der Tatsache dass Hubert airwanger an
seiner Basis durchaus viel Sympathie
entgegen schlägt und auch die ersten
Umfragen das hergeben
zu mir kommen ganz viele Menschen die
sehr große Sorge haben vor allem
Rechtsrutsch im Land die Sorge haben wo
diese ganze Sache sich weiterhin
entwickelt und ich bekomme zum Beispiel
ganz viele Zuschriften wo sich die Leute
wirklich Sorgen um unsere Demokratie
machen und ich glaube auch diese stimmen
sollte man hören auch als
Ministerpräsident und auch als
stellvertretender Ministerpräsident
Joschka Fischer hat in deutlich
gesetztem Alter als alwanger Polizisten
angegriffen er hat später dazu gesagt er
sei kein Demokrat gewesen warum ist da
jetzt ein Unterschied zu Aiwanger
ich habe Folgen ja schon formuliert ich
finde es kommt auch immer darauf an wie
man mit den Versäumnissen im
Erwachsenenalter dann damit umgeht und
Hubert Aiwanger deutet ja jetzt alles
anders er sieht sich selber jetzt als
Opfer und damit verhöhnt er die er sagt
er bereut
und er kann sich gleichzeitig an gefühlt
gar nichts erinnern diese 25 Fragen die
Markus Söder ihm gestellt hat wenn man
die Antworten durchliest da fragt man
sich ja auch wie passt es zusammen auf
der einen Seite sagt er erinnert er sich
an nichts und auf der anderen Seite
beantwortet er eine Frage damit dass es
für ihn ein einschneidendes Erlebnis war
ich persönlich glaube dass die
Lebensrealität von Schülerinnen und
Schüler nicht die ist dass man ständig
vor einem Disziplinarausschuss steht und
sich dann nicht mehr dran erinnern zu
können das wirkt auf mich und auch viele
andere Menschen nicht sehr glaubwürdig
ganz kurz noch vor Schulze hat das jetzt
noch einen Nachspiel im Landtag wenn sie
da noch irgendwie was machen
wir haben am Donnerstag eine
Sondersitzung einen Berufen denn die
Vorstellung von Markus Söder er befragt
seine eigene Regierung halten wir für
nicht zielführend die Aufklärung und
Kontrolle bringen wir also ins Parlament
und das findet am Donnerstag statt die
Spitzenkandidatin der Grünen in Bayern
Katharina Schulze vielen Dank für das
Gespräch danke Ihnen
und das Interview haben wir aus Termin
Gründen am frühen Abend aufgezeichnet 25
Fragen an Hubert Aiwanger und was der
als Antworten gibt all das zum Nachlesen
bei ZDF heute im Netz und in der ZDF
heute App
so und jetzt der Blick in die Welt mit
dir Hanna die ukrainische Armee hat
erneut Erfolge bei ihrer gegen Offensive
gemeldet laut einem General soll es
gelungen sein in der Region saporicia
die erste Verteidigungslinie der
russischen Truppen zu durchbrechen man
befinde sich jetzt zwischen der ersten
und zweiten Linie hieß es russlandgriff
unterdessen die Region Odessa mit
Drohnen an und traf dabei laut Kiew
wichtige Hafeninfrastruktur für den
Getreideexport
der ukrainische Präsident selenski hat
angekündigt dass Parlament zu bitten
Verteidigungsministerin die Kopf zu
entlassen dies solle noch in der
kommenden Woche geschehen sagte selenski
bei seiner abendlichen Ansprache das
Ministerium brauche neue Ansätze und
andere Formate der Interaktion mit dem
Militär und der Gesellschaft als
Nachfolger schlug er Russland vor dieser
ist aktuell Leiter des staatlichen
Vermögens
die ministerpräsidentinnen und
Präsidenten der 16 Bundesländer wollen
sich offenbar gemeinsam bei der
EU-Kommission dafür einsetzen das
nationale Regierungen einen staatlich
geförderten industriestrompreis
einführen dürfen das geht aus dem
Entwurf einer Erklärung hervor der dem
ZDF vorliegt und der anlässlich der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz Mitte der
Woche in Brüssel verfasst wurde in dem
Papier begründen die Länder ihre
Forderungen mit dem gestiegenen
Energiekosten die ein akutes Hemmnis für
die Erholung der Konjunktur sein
zum Abschluss seines Besuchs in der
Mongolei hat Papst franziskus bei einem
interreligiösen treffen die Bedeutung
von Religionen für den Frieden
hervorgehoben im Anschluss feierte der
Pontifex mit mehr als 2000 Gläubigen
eine Messe in der Eissporthalle der
mongolischen Hauptstadt
dabei grüßt der explizit die Pilger aus
China diese waren trotz eines Verbots
der chinesischen Regierung angereist
seit gestern ziehen über große Teile von
Spanien schwere Unwetter hinweg in
Andalusien im Süden des Landes und in
Madrid wurde die Alarmstufe Rot
ausgerufen die Behörden der Hauptstadt
erwarten dass in der kommenden Nacht der
dortige regenrekord von
1972 gebrochen wird im Nordosten des
Landes wurde wegen der Gefahr von
Überschwemmungen in einer Gemeinde mit
rund 10.000 Einwohnern ein unbefristetes
Ausgehverbot verhängt
so ist das normalerweise ein Happening
in der staubigen Wüste von Nevada Magnet
für Promis und Hippies für Künstler und
Hightech Mogule 70.000 Besucher in einer
Einöde etwas ganz Besonderes das
zusehends zu einem kommerziellen
Millionenprojekt wurde und am Ende dann
immer der Höhepunkt der Burning Man eine
überdimensionale Holzstatue brennt
dieses Jahr ist alles anders beim
Burning Man brennt nichts mehr die
Organisatoren melden Land unter nach
heftigen Regenfällen mitten in der Wüste
Chaos Schlamm und jetzt der Appell
Nahrung und Wasser zu rationieren
Claudia Bates berichtet
Matsch nichts als Matsch das Burning Man
Festival hier brennt dieses Jahr nichts
die Natur hat gelöscht Wasser in der
trockenen heißen Wüste an einem Tag fiel
so viel Regen wie normalerweise in zwei
bis drei Monaten die Polizei hat die
Zufahrtsstraße geschlossen keiner kommt
mehr rein oder raus 70.000 Besucher sind
aufgefordert Unterschlupf zu suchen
leichter gesagt als getan
ich bin am Leben aber hier findet nichts
statt wir haben alle geschlafen ohne das
Hausmusik wo Matte alles wurde gestoppt
deswegen
es ist schrecklich
beim Festival versorgt sich aber ohnehin
jeder selbst bringt genug Essen und
Trinken mit für ein paar Tage das muss
nun länger reichen
es ist sowieso ein überlebensevent man
kommt hier raus um in einer rauen
Umgebung zu sein darauf ist man
vorbereitet man freundet sich mit den
Nachbarn an es geht um Kunst und diesmal
geht es zurück zu den Wurzeln
denn Burning Man das ist immer völlig
losgelöst ein Festival in dem die Kunst
gefeiert wird gegen Kultur
hier draußen im Nichts wo jeder für ein
paar Tage seinen Traum von völliger
Freiheit leben kann der Höhepunkt ist
jedes Jahr dass eine 12 Meter hohe Figur
abgebrannt wird der Burning Man
diesmal wurde noch nichts angezündet die
feuerherpenings sind erstmal verschoben
jeder ist jetzt sein eigener Künstler
muss kreativ mit der schwierigen
Situation umgehen
ich wette dass alle sich ausziehen und
nackt durch den Matsch Rennen darüber
wird schon gesprochen
wann die Besucher das schlammige Gelände
verlassen können ist noch unklar erstmal
heißt es warten auf besseres Wetter
ja vor dem Sunshine ist dann erst noch
neuer Regen angesagt hoffen wir dass
alles halbwegs gut geht und es bleibt
bei nackt durch den schlammrennen
so Hannah du machst jetzt weiter mit
Sport und zwar mit einer Zwischenbilanz
der deutschen Basketballer bei der WM in
Asien die sich sehen lassen kann fünf
Spiele fünf Siege die Nationalmannschaft
ist weiter ungeschlagen und gewann heute
im letzten Spiel der Zwischenrunde
deutlich mit 100 zu 71 gegen Slowenien
damit sicherte sich das deutsche Team
den Gruppensieg und trifft im
Viertelfinale am Mittwoch auf Lettland
in der Fußball-Bundesliga gab es heute
zwei Begegnungen Eintracht Frankfurt
spielte gegen den ersten fC Köln
Endstand 1 zu 1 und Union Berlin verlor
mit 0:3 gegen RB Leipzig
versöhnliches Ende für die deutschen
Springreiter bei der Europameisterschaft
in Mailand nach einem enttäuschenden
vierten Platz im Mannschaftswettbewerb
gestern gewann Philipp Weishaupt heute
Silber im Einzel auf seinem Pferd
cineday blieb er der 38-Jährige in
beiden Umläufen fehlerlos und musste
sich nur dem Schweizer Steve Gerda
geschlagen geben
am Ende dieser Woche der traditionelle
Blick auf das was kommende Woche ansteht
hier ist unser heute journal Ausblick
von Carolina Freitag
[Musik]
ihr Studentenprojekt zu einem der
erfolgreichsten Unternehmen der
Geschichte werden würde hatten Sergey
brain und Larry Page wohl selbst nicht
geahnt am 4 september 1998 Gründen Sie
Google ink heute sind die Suchmaschine
und viele weitere Google-Produkte aus
dem Alltag nicht mehr wegzudenken eine
Vormachtstellung die auch viel Kritik
hervorruft
in München wird sich ab Dienstag alles
rund um Autos und die Mobilität der
Zukunft drehen in der Innenstadt und den
Messehallen der Internationalen
Automobilausstellung dort treffen die
deutschen Autobauer auf erstarkte
Konkurrenz vor allem aus China das
bezahlbare E-Autos anbietet wie schon
bei der ersten Münchner IAA vor zwei
Jahren haben Gegner der Ausstellung
Proteste angekündigt
Invictus unbesiegbar sollen sie sein und
mit dem sportlichen Wettkampf wieder
eine Chance im Leben erhalten
Soldatinnen und Soldaten die in Kriegen
schwer verletzt oder traumatisiert
wurden am Samstag werden die Invictus
Games von ihrem Initiator Prinz Harry in
Düsseldorf eröffnet Harry der selbst
auch als offiziell in Afghanistan
gedient hatte wird außerdem Gast im
Aktuellen Sportstudio sein
der Sommer meldet sich noch mal zurück
die Wetteraussichten morgen gibt es viel
Sonne und meist nur dünne hohe Wolken
die Temperatur steigt bei einem im Süden
lebhaften Ostwind auf 22 bis 30 Grad und
auch in den nächsten Tagen bleibt es bei
viel Sonnenschein und nur wenigen Wolken
hochsommerlich war mit 23 bis 31 Grad
und damit sagen wir zwei hier auch im
Namen des gesamten Teams der Kolleginnen
und Kollegen hinter den Kameras danke
für Ihr Interesse
und hier gegen 0
:05 Uhr das nächste heute journal gibt
es morgen mit Marietta Slomka und
Gundula Gause die beiden freuen sich
bereits auf sie angenehmen Abend tschüss
[Musik]